hello there reject nation I'm let's
bring you in a little closer yeah look
appealing you're doing great
hi there reject nation I'm Greg album
and I'm Ken Alvarado we're gonna watch a
video from one of my favorite channels
what culture 10 well it says more
hackers we're gonna skip to this one ten
actors who wrote typecasting in the most
epic way you know who's broken
typecasting from just being funny lady
podcast villains in history yes cat
efficiently tell them what it's about
villains of history is about the worst
people of history like Caligula Andrew
Jackson or John Wilkes was actually my
first podcast episode so you can listen
to that episode but listen to all the
episodes because they're funny and great
I've got some really talented people on
there oh yeah it's a very hot people to
listen to their voices yeah go check it
out as soon as you can guys now let's
see what actors broke typecasting and
let me see if I agree with any of these
people mm-hmm
but let's face it we're just gonna shoot
a try not to laugh after this now we'll
get the most views
doing so think about it Matthew
McConaughey's somewhat unlikely have you
seen the show your detective for still
handsome chiseled better he's pretending
to be more complex breaking free of my
roles from astronauts to cowboy boys to
police bachelors and even though it's
not a villain in the strictest sense
your modest acid is still widely out of
his wheelhouse yeah don't complexity
before tea and integrity of his earliest
snarky comedic hero image in the road to
perdition on fresh out the kitchen you
be can
well since then more morally dubious
roles have sneaked did but this feels
more like ants moving do it rather than
try to make a new career for himself
shanties their monster is rooted
opportunity she was getting because of
how she looked she said herself that
jobs with no gravitas go to people that
are physically right for them and that
is the end of the story and I quote how
many for the gorgeous that I'm wearing a
model I don't have that's what it is bad
I think
eight Jim Carrey The Truman Show and
muggy romances those two years a big
deal we did with only the Cable guy's a
movie has a lot of beautiful mugging
antics in it these days Harry seems to
fit between more dramatic roles my face
you wouldn't be in a position to do that
were it not for The Truman Show comedy
films heavy on Patmos he hadn't explored
before that the script gave him the
space to react proving his dramatic
chops as he played Truman as a straight
if slightly kooky character in a very
dark perverse world
it opened a lot of eyes honey since gone
on to play more dramatic roles as the
majestic forever this was basically the
first casting
in itself and the point is very much I
always forget it yourself listen I've
heard killer Joe is a my
[Music]
[Music]
in almost seamlessly from ghosts of
Girlfriends Past it is more adventurous
material was it came to ripping off a
band-aid all right Oh number one spouse
yeah this is our even when he was
arguing and invented an exceptional
performance is to his bad guys as he did
my teat he was primarily damn what the
one punch
rolls he'd always been known for happy
was pastors entertainer at Georgia Power
in Michael Curtiz musical Yankee Doodle
Dandy it was a role that took me back to
his musical entertainment roots but he
still had to fight cats he proved
himself very rights by dazzling the
world and winning an Oscar for Best
Actor in the process three Albert Brooks
oh so good cotton only tights with the
slightest verbal the meanness under the
surface but nothing approaching in
Russia insecurities nervousness and a
touch of egotistical obsession ran
through his characters as those are very
much the pillars of his ability onstage
persona shaved his eyebrows good people
but his calm demeanor is surprising
intimidating it won't you know usual
nervous kick it is a picture of
restrained brilliance do Bruce Willis
death becomes her
overnight and surprising oh yeah even
more dramatic movies that seem to be
confirmed by your roles in the Mike's
belong Came Polly the breaker and Bruce
Almighty are the challenging roles which
double down on her
Rachel appeal it took until 2011 guy
Stan finally killed Rachel Green when
she paid toxic highly sex
[Music]
and that's our list which other actors
belong here it was wonderful that was
wonderful
loved it I wonder if the Jennifer
Aniston role of what she did there is I
heard they had to cut out a scene that
was very clearly defined that she
essentially you know our words
part of the humor of that role
especially with the time in that movie
came out so even now if it came out is
that it's gender swapped yeah and that's
what makes it so hilarious so I'm
wondering feel like in a few decades
from now it'll be like anymore I think
it's hilarious row I think it's so funny
but you know what I love about the role
though is because it's putting the guy
in what's normally the girls plays
empathize maybe in a way that they
wouldn't normally another way yeah I
mean to the people on the edge who
wouldn't have gotten it you know that's
because from the guy for everything in
the movie his character is these other
engage or married so he doesn't want to
cheat on it as a significant other but
everyone rounds like but she's so hot
just do it anyway you know that is the
guide mentality and so morally if his
character was single you know would it
be the same kind of I don't know we're
getting too much into it bottom line
Jennifer Aniston
she broke typecasting pretty well that's
a good transitional one and I guess with
the way as I could probably call upon so
many different names that have
broke in typecasting but I think they
made a little bit more of a specific
list of like who has broken typecasting
and the film was a hit yeah you know
what I mean because other actors have
broken typecasting many times but their
films aren't necessarily a hit from that
hmm Keanu Reeves played a bad guy in a
movie called The Watcher I think is what
it's called never heard of it I feel
like yeah that's that's a robbery bro
typecasting but it's not gonna make it
on this list because it wasn't a hit I
think out of all the actors though
McConaughey's the one who has really
redesigned his whole image a lot because
like I don't really think of when I hear
Matthew McConaughey I'm like those
probably be some like badass prestigious
dramatic role where there was a time
where that's not at all what I thought
of when I would think of pretty boy
romantic you know charming dude but now
when I think about him I just saw the
movie Dallas buyers club just a month
and a half ago or something yeah heard
that one was amazing he's incredible
well earned that Oscar for sure to me
that's cool like they're bringing up the
example of someone like Tom Hanks who
would do like a one off of the road to
perdition but then pretty much go back
to what he normally does for McConaughey
he just he's been writing that and he's
been like telling it Santa it's not just
a fluke or a one-off thing cuz like even
with Jim Carrey you know he did Truman
Show as much as I sent this list he hops
between roles does he really you know
like I know and the more dramatic stuff
he does now no one really watches them I
heard his show was good but I could
probably count the dramatic roles on one
hand that people actually know yeah
honestly what did his dramatic versus
his other stuff it's really like oh he's
just stopped making ridiculous faces
yeah there's not been one where it's his
monster or his Dallas buyers club where
he's like really good and completely
changed I mean the Grinch but well I
think The Truman Show was a good
transition because it was still
advertised like it was a comedy you know
then you're watching walk in you're like
oh there's actually a lot more serious a
lot more nuanced in there I feel like
the one that's like super dramatic that
really hit for people was Eternal
Sunshine yes I was so good he's not
doing any Jim Carrey
see in that movie I feel like Truman
Show you still get that man on the moon
of course he's great in these other
movies I think what the reason why
eternal sunshine is so great speaks to
why a good script and a good story is so
important because eternal sunshine in
and of itself is an amazing story in the
concept and carries doing his best with
what's given to him yeah I think for it
for that you know you can commend him it
just what's coming his way
yes isn't always I thought also thinks
Charlize Theron is you know Cerner is a
superstar but it's still that weird area
where I feel like she's not as
recognized for her wide caliber of range
and she has demonstrated yeah it's kind
of weird to me like yeah she won the
Oscar for monster I say she won the
Oscar for monster yeah she did yeah I
said that right there when I said she
wanted the actor she won the Oscar for
monster and you know like her work in
Mad Max fury road was was definitely
acknowledged and people say she
outshined like anyone else in that movie
but the the physical transformation she
gave to that role I feel is not
recognized at the degree it can be
either because a lot of times when you
make a beautiful person ugly they still
look beautiful in their ugly makeup
we're in that movie like no actually
like all modeling's went away you know
she just really committed to that look
and a lot of credit goes to that and I
feel like overall her wide range does
for some reason I feel like when you get
the topic of like who are the best
working actors today I don't really hear
a lot of people bring her up when I
think she really is one of not just best
actresses were one of the best actors
working today she's not in a lot though
I'm sure she doesn't she's taking a
backseat a little bit it's like yeah in
terms of like big movies too you know
like she has one movie coming out with
like Seth Rogen later this year it's a
romantic comedy but yeah I don't know I
feel like you know with other actresses
well here like emily Blunt's name a lot
or yeah and there are great actresses
that are wonderful I'm like why don't I
really hear Charlize Theron in that
conversation even speaks to the whole
thing about being too attractive she is
so pretty and a lot of what's in right
now with
fasting I think is you want people who
are human they've got some kind of a
quirk about their face that makes them
more ordinary and relatable and every
person yeah
even Emily Blunt I don't want to
criticize she's beautiful but even like
she's got a certain uniqueness like her
nose yeah like Bowlby you know which
well it's not really a flaw but it kind
of does like ding it a certain amount
compared to Charlize Theron who's just
perfect was like a god she is yeah she's
really out of magic know what she is you
know I can't relate with gorgeous people
problems me either
what you don't think I don't mean that
right into the camera I've heard people
say that before you know like especially
you know actors my whole life a lot of
people say that before and you know of
course my mind immediately goes to oh my
god they're so self-absorbed you know
what she's saying with that quote about
the lack of range for actors and
actresses who are like tall and
beautiful I've heard people say that and
my eyes roll him like he has some real
[ __ ] problems you got but if I try to
put myself there I guess I can see with
the profession you're trying to achieve
and the way people generally treat you
you know it's like I can't I treat
everyone equally but I think it's
society you know good-looking people and
like great-looking people in general or
treated a little bit differently yes but
no but in show biz it is it's different
for maybe the rest of the world like for
not that I'm saying I'm great-looking
but even for whatever I am which is on
the nice part of the scale of things I
would say that's fair I'm trying to be
humble here underline the word try I'm
not Charlize Theron and I'm not saying I
am but for comedy within comedy I'm very
attractive and I
in that that's sure actually I would
second that because it's a weird thing
where I've noticed with lady comedians
who are generally if they weren't a
comedian or whatever they're just
generally a very physically attractive
person there's kind of a harder game for
some reason for them and that's just not
for me like hearing them compact I see
it I had to see it on the internet I see
it the way people respond the haters
because people want to hate they want to
bring someone down who's more attractive
and then there's the politics of it you
know with other girls who are attractive
and
the cliche goes if you're a woman you
know who's ugly then you should be a
comedian that's like the old cliche it's
a messed-up cliche yeah and then even
when it comes to booking stuff
especially paid gigs in the in the
college market this is just something
that a manager told me she's like okay
you have two ugly yourself up because
these girls are intimidated that those
are my words these are something that a
manager said to me I don't really follow
that advice I mean I was told the same
thing and then the channel blew up
really look like he did my hair got my
six-pack back all those things no but it
is hard but then it's it's possible
because look at iliza shlesinger
and Whitney Cummings I do be typecast I
know this is a second list to somebody
done before so I don't know who would
they listen the first one but I'd say
Steve Carell similar went to I feel like
he's mastered the thing they talked
about was Jim Carrey yeah he's that dude
who can easily go between like a really
hardcore comedy and a very intense
dramatic project you're not like no no
they fold their arms like you you expect
that out of the guy now like you know he
can do both no problem yeah and that's a
rare thing and I feel like I don't know
what movie it was where he really broke
that mold I know Dan in real life was
like the dramedy department does
anything Steve Carl's comedy lends
itself for something to be dramatic I
don't know exactly which one I was like
Foxcatcher and like big short got him a
lot of recognition but there was one
movie or must have must have been it
were like this guy's a great dramatic
actor you know
so yeah this is great list thank you
what culture
thank you for your videos you guys can
subscribe to rock culture subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification Bell check us on patreon
follow up Kat Alvarado on social media
this ugly disgusting looking comedian I
know I've got a face for radio which is
why I have a podcast which you should go
check out villains in history because if
you don't want to look at this white
trash who's not white latina mm-hmm go
check out her podcast support the
[Laughter]